[Music]
so uh this uh free op how do you say
this i think it's just free up free
reopp dot org yeah they just did a full
comprehensive rate of return analysis on
college and it's called is
college worth it and it's from
freeop.org
f r e one e
o p p
so this report assesses the economic
value of nearly 000 bachelor's degree
programs at 1775 colleges and
universities across the united states
very interesting detailed study on this
four in five engineering programs have
an roi above 500 000
wow you get a degree in engineering you
will make your money back and make an
extra 500 000 over your life
at least
as a result
of having done this but
what was the number was it one in 16
what was the 16 number 16 have a
negative roi of all programs so almost
one in five
of all not engineering of all degrees
so when you get this degree in you pay
too much for it
at some kind of a famous school
because you wanted to go to a famous
school
or you study something that's just dumb
you're just dumb for getting a degree in
that
it's kind of weird that we're dumb about
education but we are and that's just
dumb to get a degree in this nuanced bb
stacking
underwater bb stacking i've got a
master's degree in that you know i've
got a master's degree in
czechoslovakian medieval art that
doesn't roi you're not going to make
money on this dude this is going to be a
long there's only one thing you can do
with that become a professor of
czechoslovakian art that's all you can
do there's no jobs for that except it's
starbucks that's it
and so you're going to be a barista
that's what you're going to be and
there's no roi on your czechoslovakian
medieval art degree so this is the thing
like
it's crazy yeah and it goes on to say
here and this is no shocker that the
bachelor's degree programs like
engineering computer science uh
economics nursing they do have a
positive roi but when you start to go
into art music philosophy religion
psychology it says students can be
financially worse off than if they'd
never gone to college at all
and so that scares me and a lot of
people are they're not thinking about
college choice and they're not thinking
about the roi of their degree and we
talk about how we're not against
education we just want the education to
match the goals so if you want to be a
nurse yes you got to go to school but if
you want to go into art unless you want
to be an art teacher you may not need to
go get a four-year degree at the ivy
league school
yeah and uh after accounting for the
risk of dropping out roi for the median
bachelor's degree
drops to 129 000 on average that's the
median over a quarter of the programs
have a negative roi elite schools like
caltech and penn dominate the list of
the highest roi programs but attending
an elite school is not a golden ticket
some ivy league degrees have negative
roi and let me just tell you it's it's
hard to get an roi when you pay 200 000
for a bachelor's degree
i don't care what it's in
it's hard to get a return on that
investment and and versus if you have
paid sixty thousand dollars for that
same degree from a state school you
would have gotten the same freaking job
by the way
the same exact
job
if you got you know a degree in i.t
security four-year degree in information
systems specialization in i.t security
excellent degree field you got a degree
in supply chain oh my god obviously we
need some of those people working right
now and so um you know you got a degree
in that that's a big time job i mean
most of those jobs people are coming out
state school making 85 000 bucks right
now with an undergrad no no masters okay
and that's a legitimate roi and you paid
60 000 bucks for that or less for that
degree but if you wanna go freaking over
to some ivy league and pay two and a
quarter for that it doesn't roi as quick
and and even when it does it's not as
good obviously because you overpaid for
the same virtually the same education
yeah i almost fell into that trap i
almost went to film school and it cost
200 grand for four years and i didn't
even know about ramsey and i thought
this doesn't sound like a good idea i
don't know that i'm going to be the next
big director so maybe i shouldn't spend
200 grand on film school
so there's a lot of mistakes people are
making and it all comes down to parents
guidance counselors the college industry
there's so much pressure that these 17
18 year olds are feeling to make the
biggest financial decision of their life
well and
across the culture we've lied to them
that you have to get a college degree to
succeed a not true
b
the implication is is that getting a
college degree in something stupid
is okay
it's not okay
c going to any stupid school and
overpaying is okay that's not okay
either
so get a degree that you don't pay a lot
for in something that causes you to
actually go into the marketplace and win
boom there's
you know but i mean the meme that's
going around i saw it the other day on
instagram the one time a month i'm on
there um said uh
you know here's jim the philosophy major
uh who hasn't had a job in two years and
he lives in his mother's basement or he
lives in his whatever and here's joe
who jim makes fun of because he doesn't
have a college degree making eighty five
thousand dollars a year as a lineman
he's cutting off jim's electricity right
now so that's the meme that's a good
meme so that you know that's that's it
that's what's going on so check it out
borrowed future.com
make sure your teens are watching this
degrees and knowledge are important
doing them stupid
would be a bad idea